bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette suite là
que tu préparé par la rédaction nous
sommes le mercredi 4 septembre voici les
titres que nous allons développer ce
soir la ville de montigny le bretonneux
accueille le district de football des
yvelines c'est officiel l'inauguration
des locaux vient même d'avoir lieu quels
seront les enjeux de cette implantation
nous y répondons tout à l'heure la
cigarette électronique est nocif pour la
santé et dans question qui fut que
démontre un risque d'absorption de
substances cancérigènes les précisions
de spécialistes dans ce journal
les agriculteurs qui assurent le
spectacle lors du 60e festival de la
terre c'était à rambouillet ce dimanche
objectif lever le voile sur leur
profession et pourquoi pas susciter des
vocations et avant-premières de
gibraltar dans les salles le 11
septembre ce film sortira mais il était
déjà hier soir à montigny le bretonneux
une partie de l'équipe du film était
présente notamment julien leclerc le
réalisateur
à noter également qu'à la fin de cette
édition nous ferons le point sur la
rentrée dans l'académie de versailles
avec elle le recteur pierre yves
dubreuil l image du jour là voici les
enfants de trappes scolarisés en
primaire qui se rendent à l'école
mercredi matin c'est une première il va
falloir s'y habituer
elles la réforme du temps scolaire est
en vigueur dans cette ville de trappes
depuis hier apparemment personne n'a
oublié de faire sonner son réveil et
c'est finalement la bonne humeur qui
l'emportent elles réactions de quelques
enfants au micro d' elodie moines
d'avoir à l'école le mercredi café
szavay puis déconner c'est mieux
qu'avant et c'est bien tenir le matin
c'est marrant c'est la loi parce que les
gens qui font du sport il aimerait bien
y aller mais vu que c'est le madex et le
matin et parfois c'est bien mais
ça gêne un peu parce que c'était bien le
mercredi on pouvait s'amuser mais c'est
bien quand même dalle à l'école aussi
parce que parfois je m'ennuie et moi
mais dallas l'école ça fait plaisir de
voir ses copains et ses copines
j'ai d'école après la haute finance
avait décollé à bord après j'aurai
beaucoup fatigué il y aurait pas le
temps de faire tous moi j'aime bien
aller à l'école et parce qu'on s'amuse
au fait des activités ont travaillé et
moi j'aime mieux
c'est donc à montigny le bretonneux que
vient de s'installer le district de
football yvelinois à la ville n'était
pourtant pas le premier choix des
décideurs locaux les explications sur
tous les enjeux de cette implantation
avec anthony rech et patrick jacques de
dixmude dans le projet initial le
district devait poser ses bases à
elancourt dans le parc des sports guy
boniface une surface de plus de 1300
mètres carrés alors imaginez pour un
budget global de 1,7 million d'euros
une facture à laquelle le conseil
général devait apporter une aide de 360
milles euros
mais en novembre dernier revirement fini
l'aide départementale
les dirigeants du ballon yvelinois ne
peuvent plus assumer l'opération la
fédération nous a aidés par un près de
150000 euros sur 10 ans au taux zéro
parce que ce qui est important et par
une subvention du fonds d'aidé au
football amateur de 150000 euros et tout
le reste a été financé par la cession du
siège et par les prélèvements sur nos
réserves et provisions qui avaient été
amassés autour au cours des des 15
années précédentes de ressources qui
permettent de ne pas faire appel à la
participation financière des clubs
illinois les locaux de montigny le
bretonneux sont alors vite choisi
montant des travaux 1,2 million d'euros
sur 800 mètres carrés
à l'heure actuelle le comité des
yvelines emploie 9 personnes
autre sujet dans ce journal consacré à
la cigarette électronique la revue 60
millions de consommateurs et réaliser
une étude mettant en avant les risques
cancérigènes du vha potage les
revendeurs dénonce la véracité de l'
enquête scientifique
il faut dire qu'ils sont déjà bien
implantés dans les principales régions
de france et notamment dans le
département des yvelines catherine
château et jonathan vilma la cigarette
électronique représentent elles un
danger pour la santé dans son numéro de
septembre le magazine 60 millions de
consommateurs sème le trouble en
révélant que des composés nocifs peau
anciennement cancérigènes serait
contenue dans les vapeurs et selon le
mensuel en quantité non négligeable
comme le formol la colline ou encore le
glycol c'est évident que ce ne sont pas
des produits qui sont chouettes à une
année et c'est aussi ce qu'on demande
c'est dans quelle mesure est ce qu on
inhale ses produits
comment est ce que ces produits ont été
montrés du doigt alors qu'ils n'ont pas
été montrés par la première étude qui a
été demandé par le gouvernement qui est
quand même une étude officielle et qui
est une étude scientifique bien plus
scientifique que ce que j'ai pu lire
jusqu'à présent sur 60 millions de
consommateurs qui ne donnait absolument
ni chiffre ni protocole dans cette
boutique ouverte en mai dernier qui
compte déjà 3000 clients les
utilisateurs tempère nocifs
effectivement cela ces derniers temps en
temps parler ça mais est-ce que c'est
plus nocif que la cigarette en elle même
je pense pas il ya moins de produits
peut-être dedans nocifs
donc si ça peut nous aider dans un
premier temps un tout simplement à
passer sans le goudron enfin qui tous
les produits et puis après complètement
arrêtées pourtant du côté du corps
médical on est partagé pour ce médecin
de toussus le noble
il ne faut pas se tromper de cible il
faut je pense utiliser ce type de moyens
soit dans le sevrage tabagique soit tout
simplement parce qu'il ya des personnes
qui veulent peut être essayer entre
guillemets de fumer ou de papoter à ce
moment là beaucoup moins nocif de
prendre une cigarette électronique que
exactement la presse ibérique classique
avec ses 4000 composé donc plus de 50
on va dire cancérigènes jusqu'à preuve
du contraire puisqu'on n'a pas d'études
sérieuses et puis donc on va dire
certifiés je pense que exactement la
cigarette électronique reste exactement
un moyen un bon compromis
dans banias de la cigarette classique
nous sommes à la maison d'espagne à
versailles joël houda cette infirmière
spécialisée en tabacologie elle reçoit
des personnes qui veulent arrêter de
fumer
un patient sur trois lui pose la
question sur l' usage ou non de la
cigarette électronique et sa réponse est
sans ambiguïté
a priori ça peut devenir un produit
dangereux dans la mesure où il y a
des traces de produits cancéreux nous on
peut pas conseiller le produit dans la
mesure où il n'y a pas eu donc d'études
faites et d'autorisation de mise sur le
marché
ce produit n'est pas du tout anodin
comme ça avec a annoncé par ces
fabricants actuellement la cigarette
électronique séduit plus d'un million de
personnes en france et que pensez vous
de cette e-cigarettes êtes-vous à
méfiant est elle dangereuse c'est notre
question du jour voici vos réponses sur
les informations qu'on peut avoir
déjà je trouve que c'est beaucoup mieux
que la cigarette classique sachant qu'
on peut penser que ceux qui luttent à
l'heure actuelle pour qu'on développe à
ce produit c'est les marchands tiaret
qui sont extrêmement puissants donc tous
les rapports médicaux disent que c'est
moins - g donc je suis pour
je pense que il doit avoir aussi la
balade dans des produits chimiques qui
doivent pas être forcément meilleur je
pense que c'est pas une bonne chose ça
serait pas en tout cas on en voit
beaucoup je moi ça me dérange pas plus
que ça je préfère ça que la cigarette
normale quand on est au restaurant je
préfère sentir ça que autre chose j'ai
une collègue qui s'en est servi et qui a
réussi à arrêter de fumer donc pourquoi
pas je pense pas je sais pas il vaut
mieux rien plus rien fumé ni
électronique ni l'autre je pense
certainement un peu mieux mais
a priori d'après ce que j'ai entendu
tous les risques n'ont pas été peut-être
suffisamment évalués santé toujours
l'association est sigaud matic recherche
des bénévoles pour mener à bien ses
projets une association qui intervient
régulièrement auprès des enfants malades
en se déguisant en clown plus qu'un
spectacle et c'est un réel le moment des
changes qu'il propose dans les hôpitaux
écouter l'une des adhérentes vous en ai
plus beaucoup plus c'est ça va en fait
ça permet de tourner à plusieurs et puis
de faire vivre l'association en fait le
seul critère c'est d'avoir plus de faim
d'avoir 18 ans et plus et le monde c'est
un profil particulier mais voilà ses 18
ans ou plus et avoir envie de donner de
partager des choses
avoir son âme d'enfant donc comme je
disais et puis après
s'engager pour un certain nombre de
visites pour l'année puis adhérer à
l'association sait combien passer le
nombre de visites ces 5 minimum par an
y'a pas du tout besoin d'avoir un
parcours particulier mais par contre il
ya une formation qui est fait tous les
mois on se retrouve à chatou à la maison
de l'eau vive et en fait on fait des
exercices d'improvisation 1 des mises en
situation et l'intégralité de cet
entretien est à retrouver dans le
magazine check-up que vous découvrirez
sur notre antenne le vendredi 13
septembre yvelinoise catherine zinc ou
jc était venu sur ce plateau le 25 mars
dernier pour évoquer le don de moelle
osseuse dans le cadre d'une opération de
sensibilisation menée à travers la
france atteinte de thrombocytémie une
présence trop en trop grand nombre de
plaquettes dans le sang elle était en
attente d'une greffe elle s'est éteinte
le jeudi 7 juillet à l'hôpital mignot au
chesnay la victime d'une leucémie aiguë
nous voulions lui rendre hommage écoutez
son témoignage dire que j'ai un cancer
du sang ça paraît comprend pas très bien
on dit j'ai un cancer du sein on
schématise où ça se trouve le sens et
insidieux et les équipes même les
médecins traitants sont un peu démuni
face à toutes ces maladies qui amène à
la moelle osseuse à parce qu'on parle de
la leucémie
mais il y a plusieurs leucémie et ça on
ne le sait pas on n'en parle pas et on
n'en parle pas assez
voilà pour ce témoignage de cette
yvelinoise qui était venu sur ce plateau
évoqué le don de moelle osseuse et cet
entretien est aussi retrouver sur notre
site internet si vous voulez en savoir
plus elle nous avait expliqué tout seul
les modalités pour pouvoir donner
facilement promouvoir le monde agricole
c'est l'ambition des jeunes agriculteurs
d'île de france et ce week end il
organisait la 60e édition de leur
festival de la terre à rambouillet un
rendez vous sous le soleil pour
découvrir les produits du terroir et
même un peu plus regardées
le festival de la terre à rambouillet et
ses produits du terroir mais aussi ses
promenades en calèche
ces démonstrations d'engins agricoles et
surtout ces compétitions inattendus
comme cette course de tracteurs
la tondeuse et est unique parce qu'elles
ont l'artiste bricoler différemment
la nôtre il faut éviter de débrayer de
freiner quoi il faut essayer de ne pas
alors le problème aussi c'est la
direction parce que les virages sont
très serrés et on a du mal à
on a du mal à tourner
ce rendez vous organisé par les jeunes
agriculteurs de l'île de france est
aussi pour le public l'occasion de
rencontres louis est venu avec sa
batteuse à poste fixe d'une machine à
l'abandon à qui il a donné une seconde
jeunesse
moi je connais du matériel j'ai vu cette
machine qui était à la pluie d'encre est
sorti et j'ai remis en route on l'a
restaurée à ça marche très bien elle
avait fait qu'une campagne de battage
elle peut tout honneur qu'ont l'acier le
tout cet été les traiter les bestioles
l'intérieur car ça c'est quelque chose
ancestrale brusquement j'ai 55 ans j'ai
vu sa tournée tout ghana en beauce et cd
marié souvenir c'est que par celle de sa
logique de genre de choses
nostalgique ou simplement curieux le
festival attire chaque année plus de 5
mai visite
y avait de l'ambiance visiblement
information pratique si vous êtes un
utilisateur de la déchetterie de magny
les hameaux un nouveau système de badges
et maintenant en service depuis lundi
une carte à puce obligatoire pour
accéder au site elle est créditée de 60
passages annuels vous sera adressée
directement à votre domicile si vous
résidez à manier les habitants des
communes avoisinantes qui bénéficiaient
du site doivent eux contacter leurs
mairies pour plus de précisions
ce nouveau système doit notamment
permettre plus de sécurité seulement dix
véhicules peuvent entrer simultanément
sur le site culture à présent mercredi
prochain dans les salles les spectateurs
découvriront gibraltar le nouveau film
de julien leclercq réalisateur de
l'assaut au casting de cette histoire
vraie et qui voit un indic de la police
se laisser tenter par les promesses de
narcotrafiquants figure gilles lellouche
ou encore tarime hier soir une partie de
l'équipe était présente à saint quentin
en yvelines pour une avant première aura
lieu de vie si patrick jacques de
dixmude les ont rencontrés
ce qui m'intéressait c'était c'était le
fait de faire un film d'une heure 50
on démarre avec un personnage ce qu'on
appelle un family man un père de famille
standard le voisin que tout le monde a
et ce personnage qui est absolument
normal comme vous et moi se retrouvent
au fil du film face à des mafias
marocaine des douanes anglaise des
douanes françaises se retrouvent à
convoyer de la cocaïne et pour trouver
une solution pour nous donner un peu
d'air à ses 1 contre 1 données qui me
fait une proposition
tu comptes parlant c'est tous les mecs
qui passent par ici tous les trafiquants
squash au hasard puisque j'ai gagné 10%
de tous convaincus par yahoo là mais pas
assez bien et ne s'est pas ne paraissait
pas au pathos et des crédits qui
s'accumulent courageux pas remboursé
c'est sa neutralité c'est ça notre vie
désormais tulmont fait dans la drogue
monsieur duval ont pu la convertir leurs
gros billets en armes de guerre j'étais
proposé pour une opération de convoyage
au fait pour la publicité monsieur les
vannes d'une grosse saisie de drogue ça
montre aux gens que les douaniers sont
aussi importants que poppy et que tu
fais ta famille lieu cette semaine en
protection à mettre tous à des marques
d'une envie de m'inscrire dans un cinéma
plus large et comme j'avais du temps il
me j'avais six mois je crois sans rien
faire je lui parlais à des amis dont
hugo sélénia qui est un producteur il
m'a parlé de ce projet là et comme c'est
abdel raouf dafri qui écrit et on a déjà
fait de collaboration ensemble je l'a
appelé et j'ai rencontré julien oui donc
lu le scénario la rencontre s'est très
très bien passé et et après ce qui
m'intéressait là dedans c'était de ben
justement de jouer autre chose quelqu'un
de plus mature d'ambigu et du cul du cul
du côté de la police et c'est
l'ambiguïté qui a dans le personnage 7
cette envie d'aller plus vite que la
musique de vouloir gravir les échelons
très vite se rendre compte que
finalement on est inscrit dans une
machine qui est plus forte que nous et
qui va finalement interrogées sont sa
fidélité à ses principes
j'ai plus confiance en toi mais les
matières de confiance en pierre thomas
sarko trafiquants quoi je travaille
quant à moi je travaille pour les doutes
du temps pour toi
c'est un des pères du pas confiance
d'accord ou est une chose à faire un
isolé
tout est vrai à 92% dans le film j'ai
modifié quelque chose pour quelques
petites choses pour pour en faire un
objet filmique tel que je le voyais mes
mais les quantités de shit de cocaïne
les les rencontres entre les personnages
les rapports sont véridiques et c'est ça
qui est incroyable et une histoire forte
en juillet et août marqué par de fortes
températures septembre semble prendre le
même chemin jusqu'à 30 degrés
enregistrés aujourd'hui dans le
département ce qui est ravie forcément
la base de loisirs est cet été le
village sportif qui était installée à
attirer plus de 2500 personnes
plus de mille enfants ont profité de
tours à poney et la caravane de la croix
rouge a initié 450 personnes aux
premiers secours et la piscine à vague
n'est pas en reste on écoute le
directeur de ce site au micro d'anthony
rech
on va dire bien mieux que la première
moitié d'année puisque on a une première
moitié d'année catastrophique que
viennent un peu mais pas totalement
compensé les mois de juillet août qui
ont été globalement bo1
je vais très très beau mois et puis -
août même s'ils étaient un petit peu en
dessous globalement laisse une
impression de vacances estivales très
correct pour donner quelques chiffres
par exemple sur les secteurs sur la
piscine à vagues on a accueilli environ
40000 personnes sur l'ensemble des deux
mois contre 30 mille la dépasser et le
bilan de cette année pourrait encore
profiter du beau temps la base de
loisirs de ce début du mois de septembre
les barbecues continue à attirer les
visiteurs on se demanderait même si
l'heure de la rentrée a bel et bien
sonné patrick jacques de dixmude s'est
invitée à la table de quelques visiteurs
du site trappistes les braises commence
à rougir la glacière est pleine
tous les ingrédients pour une après-midi
réussi semblent réunies il faut la bonne
viande et
boire frais et puis toujours pareil
habite et a fumé au fût et puis surtout
surtout une bonne cordialité une bonne
camaraderie et bien des bons amis autour
des métiers d'art de trique
un peu plus loin sous les arbres une
autre famille habituée de la base de
loisirs est venu profiter du soleil
saint quentinois avant la rentrée
au menu salade de crudités poulet porc
grillé cuit à l'asiatique a fait des
barbecues rigoureux surtout celle des
enfants même si je suis venu pour
surtout pour les enfants parce que c'est
bientôt la rentrée scolaire
j'en profite et un peu parce que via bon
on pense que dans trois jours sur la
rentrée scolaire est ce qui fait que bon
quand on n'aura pas fait beau temps
après et avec les mains c'est encore
meilleur
après s'être régalé les enfants
profitent du hamac
pendant que les adultes rinck une
dernière fois aux vacances mais
attention à consommer avec modération
on laisse la base de loisirs on en vient
à l'entretien de ce 4 septembre le
recteur de l'académie de versailles nous
a accordé un entretien pour revenir sur
les enjeux de cette année scolaire
création de poste un renforcement du
lien également entre les écoles et les
collèges
et puis également les rythmes scolaires
il répond aux questions de quatre exact
de catherine mulato bonjour recteur de
l'académie de versailles alors cette
rentrée c'est une rentrée avec plus
d'élèves et du coup plus de moyens
puis ce poste voilà plus d'élèves
environ 11000 élèves de plus dans
l'académie pour mes secondes et
confondus publics puissent priver et
plus de postes voilà c'est toujours
quand même plus facile de faire une
rentrée avec
plus de postes surtout qu'il ya plus
d'élèves mais les poids supplémentaire
ne vont pas uniquement être utilisé à
accueillir les élèves puisque au delà
des postes nécessaires pour l'accueil
des élèves
il ya effectivement des postes pour
d'autres actions et beaucoup de
nouveautés on va en parler vous l'avez
dit c'est une la préparation comme était
l'étendue de cette rentrée passionnant
très particulière pour le ministre a dit
c'est d'unir entrées les plus compliqués
des ces dernières années tout est rentré
sont compliquées un très honnêtement et
donc cela est la complication de cette
rentrée c'est que ces moyens
supplémentaires sont pourvus sont ces
heurts qui sont implantées dans
l'établissement et les écoles seront
effectivement effectué par des
professeurs qui sont en cours de
formation
le mot qui est employé aussi pour cette
rentrée c'est le mot de 13 en tout cas
de justice sociale alors comment ça va
se concrétiser par quels moyens
particuliers alors les moyens six
blessés que sur les 839 emplois qui sont
effectivement plus dans cette académie
une partie une grosse moitié vont être
utilisée pour l'accueil d'élèves en
supplément et puis il reste des moyens
supplémentaires pour améliorer la
situation à une résolution dans quel
objectif
l'objectif de justice sociale comme vous
l'avez mentionné à l'instant et la
justice sociale c'est aller chercher
l'échec scolaire là où commence à se
faire à ce nous est à la fois en termes
de l'enseignement du premier degré d'où
la prière du premier degré et dans les
zones où effectivement l'échec scolaire
est trop à voir d'où la priorité au
premier degré avec des actions comme
plus de maîtres queux de classe puisse
mettre côte à ça veut dire que dans une
école lui à 12 13 classes y aura m de
plus qui va intervenir dans les classes
encore sur des domaines spécifiques sur
les projets d'école dans une école en co
animation juste un professeur plus dans
la classe avec le deuxième professeur il
faut qu'ils soient dans une des classes
des professeurs où il sera sur un niveau
il aidera les professeurs et conforme
compléterait l'enseignement des
professeurs
de cp ou de cm1 qui renforcera la
présence de lecture il faut que ces
choses comme ça et puis l'accueil des
élèves de moins de 3 ans où il est
important soitec et demi où il n'est pas
suffisant d'aller effectivement
permettre à des élèves qui sont
effectivement un peu loin de l'école des
familles qui sont à colin de l'école de
commencer à des apprentissages je veux
dire un peu plus tôt que dans très
content voilà ce sont ces mesures il
faut être prises l'école c'est important
il faut aller le plus loin possible pour
développer son talent et aussi pour
pouvoir s'insérer dans la vie sociale on
va parler du mathan du lien écoles
collèges et demain ce sera un socle
commun j'ai l'impression que c'est un
défi énorme de ce socle commun donc
comment il va se mettre progressivement
en place à ce qu' il ya déjà des choses
qui se font entre des écoles et les
collèges du même secteur
mais demain ça va devenir une obligation
jeu se clôt maman dans dans cette
académie mais comme dans d'autres salles
ont consisté d'abord de par la loi sur
la france on décolle instituer un cycle
commun
à trois niveaux d'enseignement à 3 trois
classes dont le cm2 et la classe de 6ème
partir du moment où il ya un cycle
commun ça veut dire que il y à une
continuité
maxime acolytes et or au change
l'établissement
donc il faut effectivement là sans
écriture et on change de culture et on
change on a un maître n'arrêtait plus de
modes de l'autre côté donc il faut
s'organiser de manière effectivement à
ce que les professeurs puissent de
travailler ensemble se parler et surtout
organiser la continuité pédagogique
le cycle va être commun avec la réforme
des programmes situés par le ministre en
2015 il y aura effectivement un
programme qui sera commun ces trois
niveaux d'enseignement fins et 3e cycles
et donc il faudra que les pratiques
oenologiques s'articula sud donc voilà
dans cette académie
évidemment toutes les conseils seront
mis en place mais on part pas de rien on
parle d' équipe qui déjà se parlent
d'activités communes de formation
commune dans une logique d'articulation
des pratiques pédagogiques puisque le
cycle est commun aux cm2 au sixième fois
autre chose importante cette année les
rythmes scolaires fois ci c'est
important mais en fait il ya peu de
communes quand même qui passe et s'il
modifiait le rythme scolaire de cette
rentrée de septembre notamment dans les
yvelines entre guillemets que neuf
communes sur sur 262 alors qu'elle vit
donc vous vous tirez vous vous souhaitez
que les communes présentes celles qui
n'ont pas adhéré présentent leur projet
d'école à la fin de cette année j'ai
envie de dire c'est quand même très
ambitieux ah c'est trop ambitieux mais
mais l'objectif est un exemple important
c'était le sujet y compris par la
ministre évidemment
très fortement une réforme à laquelle il
tient je suis ce titre c'est que les
ouvriers scolaire dans le premier degré
participe la justice sociale on sait que
appartements les temps d'apprentissage
sont trop compressé sur trop peu de
jours on apprend mal on va dire on
apprend moins bien j'en apprends moins
bien à l'école dans des familles plutôt
aisées on va compenser en effet mis en
situation plus compliquée on va moins on
va me convenait donc le fait de faire
des cours le mercredi matin dans une
gestion peu plus sereine que les lundi
mardi jeudi vendredi en fin d'après midi
c'est une manière de mieux apprendre à
l'école mieux apprendre à l'école c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont des difficultés de le
faire mieux d'accord mais ça coince un
peu au niveau des communes alors voilà
ont des difficultés aussi pris sur sa
blessure de leurs enseignants ont aussi
peut-être des problèmes aussi financier
pour le moment bien sûr qu'est ce que
pouvait faire mais je crois qu'on les a
incités à aller un peu plus vite
je crois que ce principe a été bien
compris par les communes fois que fait
que une fois qu'on a effectivement bien
fait comprendre ça aux communes qui
l'ont parfaitement intégrés évidemment
le reléguant laura dee désormais vous
avez un temps dans lequel vous allez
intervenir pour aider et périscolaires
et donc ses lacs effectivement dans un
gros travail a été fait dans l'académie
ici tout est communes ont été touchées
de le débat a eu lieu à la fois
collectivement avec les communes et
j'anime et moi-même un centre de réunion
lé directeur académique aussi les
inspecteurs du coach national sont
déplacés au fond des rayons de bassin et
ses accès ont je crois que le travail
est bien et bien préparer simplement
toutes les communes n'ont pas pu être
prête en septembre
pour septembre 2013 oui très loin de là
nommé toujours haussière que le travail
est largement fait largement entamée et
que les esprits sont mûrs sont claires
et qu' il dise reste plus qu'à finaliser
les projets le travail de conseil le
travail de proximité est fait est fait
remarquablement mais vous avez mentionné
quelque chose qui est vrai c'est que les
communes qui ont peu de moyens
évidemment difficultés à les mobiliser
c'est normal donc normalement elles ont
pris un peu d'élan sachant que devant
2014 donc pour voilà se donner les
moyens de le faire
et deuxièmement il peut avoir des
difficultés pour retrouver des personnes
mais c'est une réforme difficile et
ambitieuse parce que les enjeux sont
extrêmement importants il s'agit
vraiment de rares ti-cul l'ensemble
c'est négatif n'était pas question non
plus de laisser les élèves en dehors des
écoles après que le temps
d'apprentissage scolaire soit terminée
il fallait effectivement qui est une
articulation est plus commune donc c'est
une réforme ambitieuse qui mobilise
beaucoup d'argent il ya deux ans pour la
faire je crois que le travail
préparatoire a été très très bien fait
et les esprits sont mûrs 10% des écoles
sont passés en 2013 les autres mon avis
sont en état de passe en 2014 parce que
les en fait travail préalable d'accord
merci en tout cas pierre yves dugua il
va répondre à nos questions merci à vous
nous refermons le 7-8 l'aktu de ce 4
septembre il est à retrouver sur notre
site internet
comme l'ensemble de nos émissions et de
nos reportages rendez vous demain 18h
excellente soirée sur tv fil 78 vous
retrouverez notamment un nouveau numéro
de kiosques le magazine culturel avec
aurélia de bissy qui fait également sa
rentrée
on se quitte avec ces quelques réactions
d'enfants ce matin attrape alors qu'il
découvrait la joie de l'école le
mercredi matin ils étaient ravis
à l'école le mercredi sapée savez puis
déployé c'est mieux qu'avant et c'est
bien souvent le matin c'est marrant
c'est marrant parce qu'il ya des gens
qui font du sport il aimerait bien y
aller mais vu que c'est le mac index et
le matin et parfois assez bien mais
ça gêne un peu parce que c'était bien le
mercredi ont prouvé sa musique mais
c'est bien quand même dans la l'école
aussi parce que parfois je m'ennuie et
moi mais dallas l'école ça fait plaisir
de voir ses copains et ses copines
j'ai d'école après latin finisse avec
l'as rome aurait après j'aurai beaucoup
fatigué j'aurais partant de partout moi
j'aime bien aller à l'école il parce
qu'on s'amuse au fait des activités ont
travaillé et moi j'aime bien